thank you for being with us thank you
very much for having me
uh i'm excited to see whose mic is
warmer
uh i think mine this might just be a is
this a real mic or is this a prop
it's a real mic wow uh mine is a real
mic i
i didn't know we i got this from larry
king years ago
uh your mic is very it looks like you're
taking an online course right now
yeah i was saying it's like somewhere
between that and uh
infowars
it's all going to [ __ ] i don't know i've
never seen it before as i
said i don't know what they say yeah i
like it yeah doing an impression of
something you've never seen
that's how i got snl it's pretty
you did impressions of people that you
didn't really know
yeah yeah i was like this is george bush
they're like now now here's my humphrey
bogart i've never seen his work but come
on guys
let's get going it's actually not too
far
off no towards the end that's what he
was doing um
i like to start by asking people because
i i care
actually i've been instructed to act
like i care how are you andy how are you
doing during quarantine how's your
family
uh what's going on conan thank you for
asking
uh you know
not great but great are you getting
through it okay
i'm i compared to what everyone's going
through i have no complaints but you
know
it turns out being in a quarantine sucks
yeah
i'm you know missing seeing friends and
family and and going to work
and going to the park but otherwise you
know i don't have any active
real complaints i'm getting i would
think one plus side
is your wife uh the beautiful
joanna newsom is an incredibly talented
musician harpist yes you least in
quarantine
get to hear wonderful music all day yes
it's true i'm almost spoiled by it you
know i get to hear her play and
and practice and stuff because she's got
to stay in harp shape
which is a thing that she tells me is a
real thing right
um but i'm like kind of by
being married to her and hearing her
play a lot i've gotten a little bit
snobby about
like other harp music now oh really yeah
so like
i'll like be like a high tea you know at
a fancy hotel and there will be a
harpist and i'll be like
sucks
[Laughter]
do you ever say that to the harpist no
no yeah on the way out i'll be like oh
that was really beautiful
yeah great harp to joanna i'll be like
she's like i thought it was fine i'm
like yeah it was all just like [ __ ]
glissandos no technique
no one's talks that way about the harp
you know what's nice is art music
heart music is what they always play
when someone's falling in love or having
a magical epiphany and
you must constantly be walking around
the house
feeling like you're hearing that music
and thinking about
falling in love with your toothbrush as
you put the paste on you know what i
mean
yeah it definitely lends itself to to
sort of
uh dissonant moments where it'll be like
playing and then i'll
catch myself in the mirror and be like i
do have to go to the bathroom
this is a magical discovery and then
i'll i'll
go do that you know uh you're lucky that
your
talented wife plays uh you know as an
expert
uh harp player yeah my wife uh when i
met her was in the traveling company of
stomp
and so she all she does is stomp
all day to keep in stomp shape right
she's constantly making stomping sounds
and stomping and i'm like do you really
need to do this
yeah she's like i've got to keep this up
i've got to be ready
so every time the phone rings at home
she's like is it stomp yeah is it's
stomped or they want me back and i went
no
there's a pandemic and no no one's
seeing stomp right now and she's like
well
when the this pandemic's over i'll be
stomping again
yeah that's how my wife talks she sounds
like her yeah
she's like you know the football the the
quarterback in high school
she was the quarterback she was yeah she
was very she was very good a quarterback
of stomp
yeah welcome to my bad improv
she was also a hamburger uh
you're how old is your daughter now
three three
years old does she uh emulate your wife
at all is she interested in music
yeah you know uh there's a company lion
and healy that makes harps
and when uh when it got out that we had
had a kid they very nicely sent a very
tiny lion and healey child harp to us
as a gift right to us to her
uh and you know it's in the house now so
yeah my daughter does sometimes get on
there and sort of start strumming it and
emulating her mom it's pretty cute
that's sweet
yeah this is she emul and emulate you in
any way
can you does is your daughter ever like
to do things that you do
um i feel like it's only a matter of
time before she starts you know playing
the harp and doing some dick wraps
[Laughter]
i i feel like that's definitely what
joanna's side of the family is waiting
for
they're gonna be stoked when that hits
a great combination yeah i think that's
what the world needs more of
yes yes certainly not less of because
there's none of it now
it's gonna be yeah it'll be it's gonna
be an interesting time when she
discovers what i have done for a living
for a load of these many years
um my kids still don't know they think
i'm a realtor
uh you know yeah i have a very fond
memory
when your daughter was born days
afterwards
and it surprised me but you brought her
on my show do you remember that
i did yeah that was a very special
moment i was very proud new daddy
yeah and uh i wanted to show her off
yeah you did show her off
let's take a look at that clip right now
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
huh yeah yeah was she she wasn't injured
was she
she was fine she was fine you know i was
i was earning that dad of the year mug
that day